partis de bon matin quand on partait sur
les chemins à bicyclette
partir à bicyclette et traversé l'europe
c'est le pari de la sq endiguer rick
parcours cycliste qui relie trondheim en
norvège à saint jacques de compostelle
en espagne en france
le parcours passe désormais aussi par le
loiret 70 km au fil des canaux de briare
et du loing
[Musique]
pour attirer de plus en plus de
touristes de nombreux aménagements ont
été réalisés comme ces barrières qui ont
été installés le long du canal pour plus
de sécurité et ce chemin qui était
gravillonnée comme beaucoup d'autres a
été refait de nombreux travaux réalisés
pour un montant de 6 millions 500 mille
euros total le but revaloriser ce
territoire on peut découvrir des
richesses paysage des paysages
magnifiques dans tout ce secteur qui
peut être un moment avait peut-être
peiné un petit peu au niveau du tourisme
et ça marche de nombreux touristes comme
ce couple de retraités belges découvrent
les richesses des environs je peux avoir
un peu de documentation pour savoir ce
qu'il faut absolument voir pour eux
las candidat rick c'est une grande
première c'est magnifique ce magnifique
hier encore on a fait trente kilomètres
à vélo au s'arrête on parle un peu avec
les gens qu'on rencontre et comment
cette richesse
c'est sympathique depuis quelques années
déjà voilà on a une forte demande par
rapport à les tracer vélo un itinéraire
lots d'ailleurs nous mêmes nous avons
développé des circuits vélo donc on a un
guide sur l'agglomération de montargis
avec cinq parcours des touristes mais
aussi des locaux qui redécouvrent leur
région c'est vrai que c'est quand même
appréciable quoi surtout qu'avec le
chrono virus voilà comment on peut plus
trop faro découvre un peu la région
découvrir la région et bien plus encore
au total à ce qu'en dit derrick fait
plus de 1700 km